i have achieved everything i wanted to
with this character and sharing it with
these boys will be forever one of the
most special experiences of my career so
if it's time it's time if it's not it's
not but at the moment i don't know
gosh darn it tom don't you know the
spider-man rule you're supposed to run
it into the muck until suddenly you do a
spider-man movie that is not well
received
and then sony panics and goes we need to
start over again
you're ignoring the blueprint that has
been clearly set forth by your coaster
come on
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the interview
that i feel like we've been waiting for
for centuries
remember me for century remember that
song guys you knew this was coming pete
roll that clip you knew this was coming
from the get-go we've been like i can't
wait for an interview with the three
spider-man it's here it's long it's like
30 minutes in total i believe we'll
react comment break it down you know how
we do
hit that like button
i'm sorry swip that like button let's
get to it you beautiful sons of bees hi
there i'm pete hammond and happy to
moderate this session i am the only one
you are looking at on the screen who has
never played spider-man and uh this is
exciting i i think it's almost historic
we have
the it is historically yeah 20 years of
this franchise uh toby mcguire who of
course started it all with the first
three spiderman hi toby hello
[Laughter]
the pioneer in this and then of course
andrew garfield who carried it on in the
next two
to bring him back and now tom holland
who's completed his first trilogy we'll
find out if there's more
with bob holland right here
uh welcome and wow uh i have to say
right off the bat did any of you have
any idea
that this movie would have the impact
that it's had around the globe
beyond all expectations i think even for
spider-man i mean tom did you uh you
know having just done
the third one now
i mean i think i i always knew that this
film would be
would be loved around the world i didn't
think it would be quite
as massive as it has been you're crazy
you know one of my favorite things to do
at the minute is to go online and watch
fans reactions to you guys coming in
that one scene in particular
i i just i don't think i could ever have
imagined it as being so well received by
by everyone um
so no i mean i guess i had an idea that
people would love this movie but in no
way i didn't thought it was going to be
as big as it has been uh and it's been
you know only the last couple weeks if i
sort of really come back to reality and
come home and started to face real world
problems and it feels like we've been on
some sort of really weird dream it feels
really strange see that's why we love
tom holland because i feel like as fans
it's kind of been that way for us as
well spider-man for some reason felt
like the world's back to normal that
it's more exciting than ever
everything's optimistic and then
suddenly things started getting crazy in
the world again after spider-man came
out because we were out of our
spider-man bubble after a certain point
and then yeah him talking about checking
out fan reactions that's big part i
think tom holland so relatable and
lovable just yesterday i was watching
reactions up from the theater of andrew
garfield catching mj i would just get so
much nipple chills just from watching
those videos
tommy toby and andrew i have to ask you
though how did you get involved i mean
when they came to you i can't imagine
toby they said oh we want you to do
spider-man again
um
yeah i i
went and had a meeting with um uh
amy and uh kevin amy pascal and kevin
feige
and and had talked about they sort of
just you know
teased i think amy was like we'd love to
talk to you and you you know what this
is about
um and i was like okay sure
good chat
and then with amy you're like no i don't
amy yeah i know i know
maybe you could just give me a little
bit of information but i don't know i
was i gotta say i was intrigued
immediately like
in in that conversation
the
intention the kind of love and
celebration
of these movies and what it meant i
think to amy and kevin
was was a parent and to me when artists
or you know people who are
um
steering the creative process
have a kind of authentic genuine
intent of celebration and love it it's
just so apparent and both of them shines
through the movie yeah
i don't know i just wanted to join that
and um i'm a big fan of tom and those
movies and andrew so
it was definitely intriguing but but yes
i was also going well what what are we
gonna do
and and that was a bit mysterious i did
appreciate
what was shared but it was really about
getting together with these people and
revisiting
you know what
what was part of my history and and
getting a chance to like come together
and
um there there are personal things too
which are
um
kind of resolutions or
um a way to revisit and and
um i'm not quite sure how to put it it's
just just to get to get back into that
and
i don't want to say like close the
chapter but revisit and have certain
resolutions
um and and just join in this like loving
creative spirit
he said i don't want to say close the
chapter
i don't want to allude to certain things
that may have been re-shocked or things
that perhaps might be upcoming at some
point or other future talks of the three
of them coming together but absolutely
man i think we all kind of get where
he's coming from especially for both
toby and andrew they both had sequels in
development and they both got scrapped
and this was their chance to at least
put a stamp on it and still leave the
door open for you know the possibility
of coming back for something again down
the road there's not as much of that
longing anymore for oh man but we never
got to see them return what could have
been yeah and then they got to pay off
in this way so i think that's what
you're trying to say toby mcguire
you're the toby translator for this
whole video what about for you andrew i
thought well with tick tick boom and
with the eyes of tammy faye
we've seen a lot of andrew garfield in
fantastic performances this year alone
when i saw this movie i wasn't expecting
a third one that on that and amazing uh
to see you back in in these uh amazing
in this costume and and this franchise
so
so for you what was what was it like
going back well i was just waiting to
see if toby was going to do it and if
toby was there too
and i i was like well i have no choice
you know he
i follow toby to the end to the ends of
the earth i'm a lemming for toby um no i
but that wasn't sincerely a big part of
it you know when i was approached about
it
and again it's in a similar way to what
toby was saying it was like oh the
intention feels very pure here it
actually feels
like a great creative idea and a great
creative story it wasn't like they were
just asking us to come and say hi and
then leave again come and make us money
have us have our presence being in
service to tom
you know being in service to to tom's
journey and and where where he is as
peter parker and how i love the destiny
feeling
of um the multiverse expanding in this
film and actually that without toby's
peter and andrews peter
being present for toms peter at this
very moment he may not become the peter
parker that he's supposed to become
i love that
he gets it
maybe he would have lost his girlfriend
and that maybe he would have gone down a
darker path if if toby hadn't have given
hadn't have given um him that that kind
of mentorship moment that better angel
kind of moment
so it was those things i get chills
thinking about it even now um so so for
me it was like and it's the same kind of
um judgment call with any script or any
film it's like is this a story worth
telling and do i want to work with these
people and it was a big double kind of
capitalized yes and then it exceeded my
expectations because the way that tom
and
zendaya and jacob are as a trio
is just like
a kind of magical heaven kind of
friendship and then so welcoming of me
and toby into the into the gang and then
the way that tom works with john watts
and kevin and amy it's like it's very
open it's very free
and uh so so toby and i
felt not only welcomed but actually
given lots of permission to
to play and to to kind of find find our
way into being of service to to tom's
tom's story in this way it was just a
kind of joyful yeah a few weeks that we
all got to spend together which far ex i
i you know it could have been an
absolute not like you you kind of think
well
getting three spider-men together could
could go one of two ways
and uh i think it's a testament to the
to these guys that that it went it went
the way that it went which was a
brotherhood which is just beautiful a
lot of what andrew has said here has
been you know echoed in other sentiments
of other interviews that he's already
done i love what he talks about because
he really seems like he he just gets
what they were doing yeah i don't wanna
sound presumptuous i'm going to about
toby mcguire specifically because
sometimes i scratch my head and go did
he really watch those andrew garfield at
thompson
before you could just tell me i'm a big
fan you know and granted he's generally
more you know reserved than tom holland
and andrew garfield generally speaking
but like when andrew talks about him
like he just really seems like he gets
the intricate depth and nuance and also
the grander scale of the marketing and
everything like that yeah it seems like
he's invested in spider-man this whole
time yeah at the well before toby and
absolutely
and it's so heartening to hear just that
that that thing that's shown through the
movie like you said a brotherhood of
service of joy and celebration like all
that shines through and and he is the
perfect embodiment of all that andrew
murphy i have to say uh toby i just read
this morning sam raimi
just praising this
reunion of all three of you are the uh
you know putting you all on the screen
together and what it was in this film i
mean he loved it which is high praise
coming from
the original director here i think
how sweet i haven't i haven't seen that
yeah it just came out this morning
someone asked me one of the trade papers
and uh he just had honest high prices
did you have any kind of rehearsal time
to get used to this idea or did you just
jump in and uh you're all in your uh
spider-man uh
motif here
yeah it was uh it was daunting this is
so trippy we were a long way into
shooting before you guys showed up you
know we were maybe three months into
principal photography
and you know the the day
the other spider-mans are coming was
etched on my calendar and i was getting
closer and closer and closer and you
know the closer and closer i got the
more and more nervous i was and then as
soon as i met you guys in atlanta
i realized i had nothing to be nervous
about
but on our first
at our first rehearsal i had asked jacob
and zendaya to come with me
to just kind of be there as like
my support system like i'm going to go
meet these guys
lead the scene and i don't know how this
is going to go because we're all playing
the same character and we all have to
bring our own kind of
heart and soul into this and you know it
means a lot to them and it means a lot
to me does it mean the same
so jacob and zendaya were there on that
first day but i think it was really
strange and almost a little unfair how
they had us put the suits on and then
just jump around in front of a camera
together like that was one of the most
bizarre experiences of mine was that the
first day shot jacob and zade were there
for that to support me
but it was an amazing experience and
from day one it was a roller coaster
that i didn't want to get off
uh
and it was a lot of fun and like you
said andrew like it was so collaborative
it was so playful you know from you
cracking toby's back to you coming up
with the idea of pointing out us like
it was all stuff that we came up with
one day yeah um and it was just a lot of
fun to be able to play
with three guys in spider-man suits it
was a strange experience but one that i
won't ever forget yeah i believe what
andrew garfield said was that he
actually came up with the idea one day
or the part of the lab
because there's also the point on the
statue of liberty when they do that yeah
like twice in the movie and i think
what's so great about like hearing what
they're all saying is you know andrew
earlier said this could go one of two
ways one of the two ways could have been
just a bunch of ego but i get a lot of
sincerity a lot of genuine like he says
brotherhood amongst them that they left
ego at the door and they just worked so
yeah because it's like the ultimate
olive branch from a studio too so it's
got to feel like way more than a job but
like an actual just life moment for
these guys yeah how did you guys keep
this a secret so well i i know there's
all that pressure on you but i mean it
really was a well-kept secret and that's
a hard thing to do in the age of social
media it's not a well-kept secret
what news did you not read
the words of it though andrew you
because you were doing press for months
[Laughter]
yeah like
there man i'm like out there and
everyone's like why is that wrapping on
a press tour just denying spider-man
like
level two films i'm like dudes like
like look at this stuff
so yeah no i definitely think i had
the worst part of it yeah rust into the
world just like coincided with uh having
to lie having to lie for the sake of
that audience reaction i think so i know
i it's i equate it to like you know when
you're organizing a surprise birthday
party
for someone that you love and they keep
telling they keep saying mate just tell
me i hate surprises you know i hate
surprises but deep down you know they
will love the surprise
i justified my ethical
kind of like
unethical lying behavior i call it
fibbing more than lying
it was quite i kind of enjoyed it it was
quite fun and it kind of it felt like a
game of that game werewolf or mafia
where you you know you're the werewolf
and you have to convince everyone that
you're not so i kind of like turned it
into a little bit of a game for myself
you didn't do a good job convincing
people
you gave it away by name of the game
stuff happening i think like
there was enough doubt in in everyone's
mind going oh god what if it isn't what
if it isn't don't show up
for me yeah
so when we did it it kind of gave them
that little extra little bit of icing on
top of it already no work dude
i watched the movie with toby for the
first time and i was in pieces like this
is a deep movie this isn't just
fan service which you know it partially
is but like this is a movie that is
about a coming of age like acceptance of
loss acceptance of death
taking responsibility for your gifts and
the
guy
that tom went on and that he was having
to it was just like
having to split with with with his
girlfriend and his best friend and
sacrificed that in order it's just it's
the it's classic peter parker but it
felt totally fresh and totally
reimagined like
his origin like tom's origin story was
happening in his third movie rather than
his first like there's something so
profound so the film i feel stands alone
without me and me and toby showing up i
hope we enhance it but like you do i
think john and tom
have made just something actually that
is exceptionally
moving especially for young people you
know i think it's i think it's a
beautiful film
yeah yeah tom it is highly emotional yes
those close-ups of view you know with uh
aunt may and then and beyond and the
whole coda you know if you haven't seen
the movie hold your ears because that
ending you're doing an interview with
the three of them
ten minutes in
in the spiderman
so to play that must have been emotional
too i would think of course it was yeah
i mean it was emotional uh it was crazy
for me as an actor that this is
last time that i could potentially don
the suit so a lot of that
came from the act of saying goodbye
which is one of the biggest themes
throughout this film so you know
thankfully i was really able to draw on
my own experience and my own feelings in
those moments um
but it also felt like a huge celebration
you know this movie really is a
celebration of three generations of
cinema
uh so at times we would be getting into
these scenes that were incredibly
emotional that you know they're very
taxing
and i was so happy
to be there that i had to go at it a
different way and kind of go wow look at
my life look what's happened to me i'm
working with toby maguire and andrew
garfield and we're telling this story
and i would get emotional
at kind of how proud i was of the
situation that we were in and that what
we were doing and that i really believed
in what we were doing um so yeah it was
tough
but you know anything
hard is is worthwhile um and you know i
was happy to kind of really push myself
and and to make this film you know more
emotional than superhero films have been
in the past uh but uh but yeah so a lot
of it was i was drawing on my own kind
of feelings as we went along you know
that's something that i think tom
holland was 100 correct about when
teasing this film he's like a lot of
people are thinking that this movie was
just going to be like a lot of fun and
excitement but really it's going to be a
really dark journey i think a lot of us
really weren't expecting that when we
actually went into that movie with what
andrew garfield's talking about of how
it's not just purely fan server so there
really is a story at its core and then
for this question to segue into anime
i'm like yeah i remember watching it for
the first time i wasn't even
thinking like i wonder if toby and
andrew like i thought it early on in the
movie and i had that apprehension like
what if they don't so in the moment i
think that's something this movie does
so well is that you're so gripped by the
immediacy and the terrors of what tom
holland is experiencing at this time i'm
not even thinking about yeah but it's
toby and andrew
so when they do show up they support it
like he says it enhances it i would
actually weirdly agree that the movie is
monumental and historical for the fact
that the three of them are in there
however there is a version of this movie
that could have been done without them
being here absolutely and to me i mean
like i think of scorsese and i'm like no
that but that is cinema like what tom
just said is like you know they wanted
to make it like he's drawing on all this
real experience and everybody else is
coming at it with this very real intent
it all shines through the final product
and it is one of the more emotional and
emotionally resonant and impactful
superhero movies partly because all of
that life that went into it so like it
is cinnamon i feel like it's the essence
of cinema right there yeah toby this
feels like a culmination in fact i i did
a little interview with amy pascal and
she described it that way she said this
movie
is a culmination of 20 years what began
with you and your three and now going
full circle here uh is that the way you
look at it too when you looked at this
that this is he looks at it like that
[Laughter]
that was paycheck negotiation
well i'll say i remember being on set
and it was i believe our last day
andrew and
it was uh
it was really amazing and i had i had
the awareness of this you know the the
20 years of history but
looking at um
amy and kevin and realizing that they've
been there through all the different
iterations
yeah it was really powerful just
personally it was really powerful it was
powerful for me to be
working with andrew and tom and powerful
in a in a legitimately moving emotional
way and then
to witness
amy and kevin and consider their
journeys through all the films it was
it was really impactful um
and and yeah i was i was
just grateful every day i really it was
such a rich experience and as
the guys have touched on the kind of um
sharing of something and the the
brotherhood of it it was it was just so
rich emotional
and i i don't know i i'm not like
sitting there conceptually thinking
about that all the time but i would have
moments where that kind of stuff would
hit me you know day to day it was
it was
just a beautiful kind of unfolding of
this story and these relationships
so i was more just like in
in that uh on the day to day but i'd
have these like reflection moments which
were
quite powerful and and elegantly
woven ultimately because it's actually
you're thinking about taking 20 years of
history
and revisiting that and how do you
how do you balance um
all of these things and each each of our
kind of series of films have you know
their the characters are
we're playing the same character but
they're also unique and and the
the way those films and characters
evolved in those films are unique and
then to bring all of that together
including um
uh
you know all of our super villains and
and all of that it's
it was
pretty wild to witness the
immensity of all of this history coming
together and being put into
what andrew is saying is this you know
stand-alone worthwhile story
um and and i too just wanted to say with
with the coda
of the movie i was really
touched emotionally but also i just
thought it had such a sweet elegance to
it like that
was so amazing and i i agree in terms of
the origin story and the kind of coming
of age or or
you know
tom your character stepping into this
different kind of maturity and
responsibility
and all done with this like really sweet
sad elegant touch it was it was just
beautiful i just love how they just pay
it all to
other people
like somebody could use a beer being
like yeah i started this [ __ ] um and it
all just comes back to me and like what
andrew's talking about earlier tom's
movie wouldn't exist if i didn't kick
this off
myself people who weren't annoyed at my
movies we wouldn't have got the reboot
that let us here it is just kind of
funny listening to toby talk about it
though because from hearing the rumors
before there were like leaks actually
coming out but hearing just the rumors
about it you know watching the movie and
just me watching this interview i'm like
this is surreal and trippy to me
and i feel like if that was like that
for him the whole time that he might not
have been able to do his job for the
film yes so like he would be like yeah i
would have random conceptual moments but
it wasn't something i was constantly
thinking about i'm like well good yeah
because he has an audience remember i'm
like freaking out at the just watching
the interview but i never even
considered that journey for amy pascal
and kevin feige that he was touching on
like that is a fascinating one you know
when we met kevin feige at the
spider-man no way home premiere thanks
to koi zhandra i could have looked him
in the eyes and asked him about that
like what's this emotionally feel like
he would not remember that i met him
don't worry you can ask him the next
time and then you know what he'll say
he'll say why didn't you make that your
first impression
talk to me about who i am but now i mean
i think especially amy pascal doesn't
get enough credit for i don't know i
feel like she gets a lot of crap that
she maybe does not deserve it's a
remarkable
movie the way they did this i got a big
shout out here to john watts who i had
seen cop car and i think the first time
i talked to you tom it was with john and
when you had done the first spider-man
and all all i could do to do is talk
about this little movie cop car that he
did and think wow this guy's going
somewhere what was it like working with
john on this film for you guys andrew
and and uh
toby had not before obviously tom had
what was that experience like it's so
funny because what toby just said about
the kind of
i
in those moments of awareness where you
realize you were that we were
bringing in
20 years of history and then some into a
frame every day
that hugeness that we that i know that
we only
got a sense of in moments and i remember
maybe the first time i got a sense of it
where where i think we were on a
scaffolding and like we were talking to
dr strange who wasn't actually there and
tom turned to us and said that something
doesn't feel quite right about this it
feels a bit awkward or like we just kind
of stood here and and both me and toby
were like yeah this feels a little weird
we feel a little odd and then in that
moment john watts comes up the um
the scaffolding goes that's the movie
that's it we got it
this is this is the moment and we're all
like oh
we're insane then
we weren't seeing what he was seeing
which he then just showed us
and it was just the three of us in our
suits in the same frame
and just how
profoundly moving that is unto itself
for spider-man fans the world over and i
think it was at that point where i was
like oh no this is kind of people are
going to like this movie
[Laughter]
there's this element of things but in
regards to the bigness that toby was
talking about
it also
mostly just felt very small like we were
making cop car like we were huh
interesting just doing an independent
spider-man film and that's why the tone
of these films that tom and john have
created together feel
like
michael j fox john hughes indie kind of
um
small details awkward
beautiful humor proper deep intimate
love
stuff with huge scope but like at the
essence of it is just pure heart and and
that's what it felt like with john it
felt like there was i was just so
overwhelmed by
how unperturbed he was by what he was
trying to achieve like it was so big
objectively but
his his calmness his ability to allow
actors to improvise to play and then for
him to throw out wild ideas in the mix
to let takes run and run and run to give
us time to really find what we were
doing and to go down the wrong path to
then find towards the new path the right
path
i was just incredibly impressed and
actually just really grateful for the
experience with with john he he's
someone that
he's a real actor's director and and
that is especially
hard to feel in the midst of the
machinery
of um a film that does have this scope
and i i know that tom will
will be able to talk to that even even
better than me that's something i i have
to give john watts credit for because
despite whatever you know negative
feelings that i would have had towards
and i think this is this would be
applicable for a lot of people's opinion
actually with the other two spider-man
movies that tom holland started the
acting was always really good it was
always great even if like the writing or
the story itself was something that like
obviously became a lot better for a lot
of people ourselves included after
watching no way home the acting was
always like really great yeah that sense
of intimacy and the little details like
he said even though yeah there is the
spectacle that is a big part of those
movies yeah when you're just with the
characters it does feel i think a bit
more authentically than maybe we give it
credit for as you know some kind of more
intimate indie story we've seen great
actors in bad movies and do bad
performances so it's not just about
solely good casting you got to have the
right director who knows how to guide
you you know you got to bring those
performances out of people yeah it's
like
we've seen uh chaos walking happily
actually i haven't seen chaos
i don't even know if he does a good job
with the movie performances are great
everything else that isn't good i was a
little bit surprised by andrew
garfield's answer especially when you're
thinking about the pressure he must have
been under like i would have had a panic
attack every single day yeah it does not
feel like the hugest undertaking in the
entire universe
john and i spoke yesterday for the first
time since the film has been released
and i think it took us so long because
we needed time to just kind of let the
dust settle
and then we spoke yesterday and and the
first kind of ten minutes of our
conversation was kind of like we we're
both kind of in disbelief of what's
happened and what we've achieved you
know i'm talking to him like i remember
meeting you for for the first time in my
trailer i was 18 years old
and you were you had never directed a
movie like this before and both of us
hadn't a [ __ ] clue what we were doing
we were both like i i i was petrified he
was petrified and then on this movie
beautiful our best foot forward go on
this is so beautiful
a journey of growth um
and it's just been one of those
relationships that i've had that i will
cherish forever you know john and i have
no boundaries with each other you know
we have no fear in telling each other
how it is and being honest and i think
when you make these kind of movies it's
very important to make sure that you
don't lose the heart and soul of why you
started doing this in the first place
and i think john watts was the perfect
person to kind of keep that throughout
the trilogy uh but for me as an actor
he's kind of
he's like a gold mine he will let you do
whatever you want until you've gone too
far then he'll ruin you back in and
he'll always set you on the right track
and he's someone that you can really
trust
he's incredibly creative you know he
never sacrifices quality for quantity
you know like he is the kind of person
that will shut a scene down and say
we're done for the day we're going to
pick this up tomorrow because it's not
reaching my expectations and that's
happened a few times on this film and in
the previous two films so i've always
really appreciated him massively his
bravery to say to the studio
i'm finished for the day i'm not
shooting this scene until we come up
with something better um i think that's
an incredible quality and something i
know i could wow
i would have been like yeah just we'll
do four hours over until we figure it
out don't tell me what to do so yeah so
i've always been a huge fan of john's
and his great friend and i'm so glad
that you guys had just as an amazing
experience with him as i am i don't know
but my appreciation factor for john
watts felt just like skyrocketed
to be able to step in and be like hey
this isn't working and instead of
exhausting ourselves further we're just
going to come back tomorrow with a
better like that that's that'll take
some breaths
that's ballsy man
what does he have on the marvel
firehouse that he could do that i've
never heard that insight of like he came
into my trailer because that's right
newscaster civil war before he ever met
john watts for them to like meet up and
both be like we've never done something
like this we've had to lean on before
this is terrifying and we're stepping
into like major shoes this is spider-man
i've never even considered what that
fear factor might actually be for them
uh so to hear that and to see where they
are now i'm like oh yeah you know it's
like as much as like the celebration is
usually pinpointed towards like the 20
years yeah and then you know the three
of them coming together and of course we
really want to hear what andrew and toby
have to say because they're returning
yeah there's a big congratulations
specifically towards tom holland and
john watts that is absolutely well
deserved and it's something that i feel
like isn't really talked about i know
like we've done a lot of talking about
spider-man and we haven't really talked
about ourselves john watson
i have to ask you toby i'm sure people
are wondering so what was it like these
costumes
uh the costume designs it's you know
iconic what was it like getting back
into that suit
um well you know what once you get
through the process of you know really
peeling it onto your body
it it was
i don't know a lot of things it was
uncomfortable getting it on and then and
then it's a goof and then it also has a
sort of
um power ring
you know
i guess a sort of a power in a sense
because it brings me back into that
character it really does
um
there's so much affinity for this
character it means so much to so many
people
that you know once the sort of goofiness
of being in
uh lycra or spandex you know once that
goes away you're like oh wow this is
this is cool this is that
sort of um mantle
a responsibility but a but a blessing
like something that i get to do that i'm
grateful for
and
so that was fun but but honestly like
being with these guys it really was um
[Music]
just a much much richer experience than
i anticipated or
that i could really even express in
words i i just
i know that's not the question about the
suit but
but the suit is it just
to get to be there with these guys in
their suits and
whether it was like dancing around or
playing around in scenes and improving
um
you know
feeling that
kind of sense of service to each other
um and the character being in service to
humanity it really
gives a certain perspective and then and
then the the kind of trust and openness
that
i have with these guys and
uh john and amy and everyone it it just
brought this
really
open
i don't know i just felt super safe and
like we were all on the same team and
all in support of each other and it just
brought out this
this
yeah i don't know how to put it other
than just like this really loving
uh fun creative experience that
um
that i was just like sitting in
gratitude every day
which is not always the case when you're
working on something you know even just
from the standpoint of like
trying to figure out what you're doing
and and it all it wasn't without its
challenges
but it it all just unfolded the way it
needed to or
whatever just it had a sense of this
kind of destiny to it as well so i guess
the suit was the the doorway to that
that's cool
i have to mention the theatrical
experience here which has been
threatened and
and people say oh it's the beginning of
the end and everybody's going to sit on
their couch and watch movies at home and
things and this movie is almost
single-handedly being credited for
proving that that is not true that that
movies exist in movie theaters at the
way they were designed by their
filmmakers to be seen and this is the
perfect example of a movie
that as edgar garfield promotes his
netflix book
experience of watching this movie is
again it's like unlike
anything i've seen in a long time that
that kind of feeling you get and uh and
it's got to be preserved and so all
three of you are here part of the reason
why
movies are going to go on to give me
hope
you know for this tom tom uh you in
particular you might go on and do
more spider-man i'm going to try to get
a scoop here uh
that's the way to do it
i
the truth is that the truthful answer
and i've done a whole press tool where
all i do is lie
and you're not going to like the truth i
don't know the answer to that question
yeah
i don't know the answer you're the
werewolf
it was as special
experience could ever be
sharing the screen with these guys you
know playing spider-man can be quite an
alienating experience because you know
you know the three blokes we're the only
three blokes who have done it so to
share that with you two and for it to
have been such a wonderful experience of
which i have such amazing memories
i don't know there's part of me that
feels like it's the perfect time to
to jump off the building and swing off
into the sunset and and let the next
lucky young kid come in uh to don the
suit no i know i love this character and
i know that i am not ready to say
goodbye but if it is time for me to say
goodbye then i will do so proudly
knowing that i have achieved everything
i wanted to with this character uh and
sharing it with these boys will be
forever one of the most special
experiences of my career so if it's time
it's time if it's not it's not but at
the moment i don't know
gosh darn it tom don't you know the
spider-man rule you're supposed to run
it into the muck until suddenly you do a
spider-man movie that is not well
received yes and then sony panics and
goes we need to start over again we need
to reboot this you're ignoring the
blueprint that has been clearly set
forth by your coaster no in all
sincerity i feel like we're just getting
started with it
literally
like i love the way that movie ended i'm
like oh my god we've finally gotten to
this point where i've been wanting him
to get to you know like how andrew
garfield said earlier it's like we're
watching his origin tale unfold over the
course of three movies why would you
stop now like now let's see
the app post origin how this all goes
like there's such a rich story to mine
here oh yeah like i feel like if you
just brought in a new spider-man be like
what no like what happened
what's going on you would need to like
have someone then replace the tom
holland version and continue that same
story it wouldn't be like let's just do
another spider-man story again you know
the way he talks about lately it seems
like there's a part him that is ready to
you know hang up the suit at the same
time though it's like as a as an
audience member and like come no no just
take up take a rest yeah take some time
take your time you need to repeat take
the time you need but hey
you come back to us in six months to a
year you'll have a hankering for more
peterborough well we certainly uh can't
wait to see what you do next and all
three of you and again congratulations
uh andrew on all your other films this
year which are great and i'm happy to
say i've seen all of them in a theater
uh and uh they're all different and all
of you are big champions of independent
filmmaking too so i loved what you said
about this felt like uh an independent
film in its own way even on the scale
that it was being produced and and
you're all big champions
of that uh
throughout your career so um keep it
going and thanks for joining us here and
talking this rare opportunity to see
three spider-man together this is so
exciting thanks guys
thank you thank you
well done i felt like andrew garfield
was slowly getting specifically
just gonna
get out of the interview after a while
all right guys well that was amazing
amazing spider-man heartwarming
guys what'd you think what was your
biggest take away from that um please
you know leave your thoughts down below
we'll catch you guys soon thank you for
being here